pensemos un poco en las propiedades de
los alcoholes así que la fórmula general
para los alcoholes vimos que es algún
tipo de grupo o cadena de carbonos unido
a un oxígeno unido a un hidrógeno y por
supuesto el oxígeno va a tener dos pares
solitarios justo así comparemos esto con
el agua el agua se ve algo así tienes un
hidrógeno unido a un oxígeno unido a
otro hidrógeno con dos pares solitarios
ahora en el caso del agua el oxígeno es
mucho más electro negativo que el
hidrógeno así que atrae a los electrones
así que tienes una carga parcial
parcialmente negativa en el extremo del
oxígeno y luego tienes cargas
parcialmente positivas
tienes cargas parcialmente positivas en
los extremos de hidrógeno y eso es lo
que le permite al agua unirse a ella
misma a no tener un punto de ebullición
ridículamente bajo y déjame mostrarte
esto déjame copiar
y pegar esto
ya has visto todo esto en química
ordinaria corto y pego
déjame dibujar más moléculas de agua
aquí
y déjame dibujar otra molécula de agua
y ya que en el agua el extremo del
oxígeno tiene cargas parcialmente
negativas y los extremos de hidrógeno
tienen cargas parcialmente positivas el
oxígeno de una molécula de agua va a ser
atraído por el hidrógeno de otra
molécula de agua y ya hemos visto esto
antes estos se llaman enlaces de
hidrógeno por lo que esto de aquí
es un
enlace de hidrógeno
pero
exactamente lo mismo puede pasar con los
alcoholes pero los alcoholes solo tienen
la carga parcialmente positiva en el
hidrógeno no sabemos exactamente lo que
está pasando aquí seguramente tenemos
carbonos enlazados al oxígeno y los
carbonos no son como
son razonablemente electro negativos no
van a atraer tanto a los electrones como
lo hace el hidrógeno así que en el caso
de los alcoholes déjame dibujar en lugar
de tener esta ere como radical aquí
déjame hacerlo un poco más concreto
déjame dibujar un verdadero alcohol
un ejemplo de alcohol es el metanol
podríamos tener el metanol que se ve
algo así
tiene un hidrógeno justo aquí el oxígeno
es mucho más electro negativo que el
hidrógeno por lo que tienes una carga
parcialmente negativa aquí y luego
tienes una carga parcialmente positiva
ahí así que también debido a los enlaces
de hidrógeno va a tener un punto de
ebullición razonable no va a pasar
directamente a estado gaseoso y va de
hecho a intentar unirse a sí mismo así
que déjame copiar y pegar esto
también puede formar enlaces de
hidrógeno pero no van a ser tan fuertes
como los del agua y es por eso que algo
como el metanol de hecho tiene un punto
de ebullición más bajo que el del agua
es más fácil hacerlo el bulli es más
fácil romper estos enlaces porque no
tienes tantos enlaces de hidrógeno así
que este es un ejemplo de enlaces de
hidrógeno con metanol
ahora ya que el metanol puede tener
enlaces de hidrógeno y tiene esta ligera
polaridad y el agua también tiene
enlaces de hidrógeno el metanol es
visible en agua y lo que eso significa
es que es soluble en agua en cualquier
proporción sin importar la cantidad de
metanol o la cantidad de agua que tengas
es soluble así que si fuera a dibujar
algunas moléculas de metanol
de hecho aquí está el agua así que si
dibujas una molécula de metano la aquí
esto tendría esto tendría un enlace de
hidrógeno aquí
si dibujo otra molécula de metanol
tal vez por aquí tendrías otro enlace de
hidrógeno justo ahí y eso es lo que le
permite al metanol ser soluble en agua
ahora mientras esta cadena crece o si
tienes alcoholes con cadenas de
radicales más grandes entonces se
vuelven cada vez menos solubles en agua
pero el punto de ebullición de hecho se
eleva y pensemos en por qué pasa eso así
que si tengo algo común y déjame dibujar
al butano
el butanol va a tener 4 carbonos así que
será h
h 2
h 2 déjame escribirlo así
y luego este carbono ese último carbono
de allí va a estar unido al oxígeno va a
estar unido al oxígeno que va a estar
unido al hidrógeno y ahora cuando tienes
una situación como esta el oxígeno va a
tener una carga parcialmente negativa y
el hidrógeno aún tendrá la carga
parcialmente positiva igual que como lo
vimos con el agua y el metanol
pero ahora tienes esto grande de aquí
que no tiene polaridad esta parte del
alcohol no va a ser soluble en agua por
lo que le va a dificultar a esta parte
ser soluble en agua así que esto de aquí
es menos soluble
esto es menos soluble
y aún va a ser un poco soluble porque al
tener este oxígeno aquí aún tendrás un
poco de enlaces de hidrógeno aún
existirán enlaces de hidrógeno pero esta
parte es como
puedes imaginar que no quiere disolverse
en agua es no polar esto es de hecho
puedes desde un punto en particular
soluble en agua pero no en cualquier
proporción así que el metanol es visible
y déjame escribir esto esto es una nueva
palabra no creo haberla usado antes en
el contexto de los vídeos de química
orgánica entonces el metanol es el
metanol
simple
visible lo que significa que es soluble
en cualquier proporción soluble
l
cuál quiere
acción
por lo que no me importa qué porcentaje
es
es qué porcentaje es metanol qué
porcentaje es agua el metanol va a
disolverse en el agua en cualquier
proporción si ves al butano es soluble
pero no en cualquier proporción si
tienes una tonelada de butano parte de
él no se disolverá en el agua entonces
esto es soluble en el butano les
l
es soluble pero no
mi simple
no visible en agua
en agua
si tienes demasiado butanol parte de él
no será capaz de disolverse si esta
cadena si esto fuera aún de canon o algo
con una cadena de carbonos muy larga
entonces realmente sería muy muy poco
soluble podrás disolver un poco de las
moléculas en el agua pero la mayoría de
ellas no se disolverán y la razón por la
cual los alcoholes tienen un punto de
ebullición razonable bueno no muy bajo
es porque son capaces de hacer estos
enlaces de hidrógeno pero dirás estas
cadenas de carbono más largas
presentaran menos enlaces de hidrógeno
quizás éstas tengan puntos de ebullición
menores pero de hecho mientras más
largas sean las cadenas tendrán puntos
de ebullición más altos y eso se debe a
que estas cadenas pueden interactuar
entre ellas por lo que entre más grande
sea la cadena
más
la classe
o cadenas de r más largas puedo decir
puedo decir
mayor
mayor será el punto de ebullición en un
alcohol mayor punto
d
wood
si acción
es más difícil necesitas más calor en el
sistema o la temperatura debe de ser
mayor para que las moléculas se separen
y eso es porque esta es una molécula de
butano y otra molécula de butano puede
verse
así puede verse así tienes un oxígeno y
un hidrógeno y luego tienes a los
carbonos tienes tu ch2 tu ch2
h 2
h 3
tienes este otro butanol aquí y la
interacción entre estas dos cadenas
depende estas son las fuerzas de van der
waals esto de aquí tendrá tendrá
interacciones polares tendrán enlaces de
hidrógeno hemos visto eso múltiples
veces ya pero esto de acá tendrá las
fuerzas de dispersión del london que es
un subgrupo de las fuerzas de van der
vaart aunque sean neutras de vez en
cuando uno de éstos puede volverse
ligeramente negativo en un lado por lo
que puedes tener una carga parcial
negativa temporal
y eso es solo por el azar del movimiento
de los electrones en este lado de la
molécula de repente podrías tener más
electrones ahí por lo que tendrás una
carga parcialmente negativa y debido a
eso los electrones de aquí puede que no
quieran estar ahí por lo que tendrás una
carga parcial positiva tendrás una
interacción temporal
eso es una fuerza muy débil más débil
que un enlace de hidrógeno pero como
estas cadenas se vuelven más y más
grandes y ya que posiblemente
interactúen unas con otras y estén más
juntas unas de otras estas fuerzas de
dispersión del london o fuerzas de van
der vaart van a seguirse propagando por
lo que de repente estas partes se van a
atraer y eso desaparecerá entonces estos
otros se van a atraer y eso va a
desaparecer y luego esos se van a atraer
y eso va a desaparecer puedes imaginar
que mientras más grande sea la cadena
tendrás más interacciones de este tipo
se van a atraer más y va a ser más
difícil separarlas resultando en un
mayor punto de ebullición bueno esas son
las dos propiedades más importantes de
los alcoholes ellos son especialmente
los alcoholes de cadenas cortas son
solubles en agua los que son muy
pequeños son completamente invisibles y
mientras más larga sea la cadena será
es difícil que se disuelvan en agua pero
también será más difícil separarlas
debido a estas fuerzas de dispersión de
london